the hybrid Hyundai i10 runs on liquid
petroleum gas and uses 6.5 liters per
100 kilometers and is rated to travel
450 kilometers before switching to the
conventional gasoline engine and Germany
the Hyundai i10 with its environmentally
friendly 1.0 LPG engine and the trend
features will set you back around 13,000
euros the BMW Concept roadster provides
a first look at what could be the new
motorcycle roadster generation with a
water-cooled two cylinder boxer engine
the 1170 cubic meter engine has a
capacity of 92 kilowatts with 7750 rpm
and a maximum torque of 125 newton
metres
the automobile cartas de Montes Kurata
explains that the association of
international motor vehicle
manufacturers originally started the
automobile international and live stage
to give important makes a larger
showcase now Germany second biggest
automotive trade fair also features many
German carmakers BMW has a production
facility of Leipzig so it has nothing
less than its entire range at the am i
joining the products already out there
are some new releases
um BMW's row lon kruger explains that
this year the carmaker is presenting two
European premieres and one german
premiere the active tour and premiering
for Europe the new X 4 and the
convertible m for Porsche also has a
plant near the trade fair grounds and
will not let BMW leave it in the dust
even if it has no premieres of its own
but many of the luxury models are seldom
seen on the streets so they're just as
much a treat for the am I visitors
audi is celebrating the world premiere
of its s7 sports car the four liter v8
engine puts out a killer 331 kilowatts
of power let's know I him out what's
thoroughly knew about this one is the
design starting with a single-frame
grille in front and many other
highlights the s7 SVA twin turbocharged
engine features cylinder on demand so it
can be driven as a v8 or a v4 MIT
cylinder on demand as a macondo spot
segment as far aft far no dolls as found
a foul fear fun VW is celebrating the
40th anniversary of its golf with a
special model the gulf edition it's
joined by the sportiest and most fuel
efficient version of the compact classic
today alsa diamantis has also spotted
the series version of the beetle dune on
the VW stand it has an extra 50
millimetres clearance and an electronic
differential lock that gives it handling
like its dune buggy namesake eyecatching
is the innovative ski rack built into
the rear spoiler
the mercedes-benz stand also plays up
the luxury but without forgetting
practical concerns Edith Edith Montes
reminds us that Mercedes Benz premiered
the sedan version of its c-class in
Geneva just a few months previously and
the station wagon version the team model
and Raymond a couple of weeks ago now
here in life seek the public is getting
its first glance of the vehicle with
over 1,500 liters of cargo space and a
wide range of engines it appeals to
business travelers and Families alike
Green is scotus vision for the fair not
just because of its natural gas-powered
gtech models but because of its vision
see designed to offer a preview of the
Czech car makers design vocabulary and
years to come and technological terms
the show cars based on vw's modular
architecture
let's go to Germany head he made the
lobby stresses that right now it's a
prototype the one that's already had a
very clear impact on the company's new
models and will definitely shape models
to come tallaght opal has had a long
struggle with its public image but that
may well be over its broad range of
models and alternative power trains are
aimed at giving the make a new shine for
all classes of car buyers yavi I'm the
total sales and marketing director
Juergen Keller says along with many
innovations and it's always important
for Opel to have a german premiere in
leipzig so the adam rocks is making its
debut at the 2014 am I he says that Adam
rocks caused quite a stir last year as a
prototype so opel decided they'd go
ahead and put it out on the market
280,000 visitors came to see the
automotive industry's latest creations
at the last am i two years ago was
slightly more expected this time around
as the car makers see it the more the
merrier
you